[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
happy monday my adoring and adorable
fans i'd kiss each and every one of you
if i wasn't so contagious
but thank you again for making us the
most successful tv show
in history
i know i know i know
in history
i wouldn't believe it myself except that
there it is in a chart i made an hour
ago
you see it shows super bowl 49 final
mash episode the last episode of cheers
final game of the world series in 2016
cat you like that one and there's gut
fell in the middle
doubling all of that combined and then
some with 4 billion viewers
don't bother checking it the data's
right there
and we did it without our staff breaking
into the capitol
bet you didn't know that stuff
and why because we live in two different
worlds it's sad in one world you're the
hero and the other you're the villain i
could be thor
or i could be satan
in a perfect world i would be both
but these worlds mirror each other like
the olsen twins trapped in a fun house
for example in one world the supreme
court justice hero would be sonia
sotomayor and the villain would be
clarence thomas
in the opposite universe it would be the
reverse
fine but in this universe of two
competing movies we are told by the
media that you can't respect both sides
it's one or the other one you can adore
and the other you should hate
yep there are 64 genders but only one
worldview
so once in a while it's good when
someone comes along to remind us that it
doesn't have to be this way
take it away soto talk about clarence
i have probably disagreed
with him more than with any other
justice
that we have not joined each other's
opinions more than anybody else
and yet
justice thomas
is
the one justice in the building
that literally knows every employee's
name he is a man who keeps cares deeply
about the court as an institution about
the people who work there but about
people he has a different vision than i
do but i think we share a common
understanding
about people
and kindness towards them
that's why i can be friends with him
and still continue
our
daily battle that's awesome
and it's awesome for a reason that i've
been talking about since i hosted that
political talk show on animal planet
back in the 80s
screw you panda
i hosted it with cronkite back in the
day taught them a lot in this woke
riddled era any person seen
commiserating with another person
holding different more unsavory opinions
actually takes on that person's terrible
beliefs you're normalizing hate they
would tell you this contamination
argument is used to keep people apart if
you are seen being nice to x then the
mob on social media will come for your
scalp no offense to liz warren
and it's not just from talking to
obvious clowns but from decent people
you may not see eye to eye with and that
alone means they can't be your friends
this is not something you see among
thoughtful older adults you know the 11
left on the planet
hell even pets get this i mean how many
pictures of dogs and cats hanging out do
i have to show you
this new idea segregation is brought to
you by the non-thinkers coming out of
our campuses where allowing a
conservative speaker is considered a
violent act
but if listening to speech that you
disagree with is tantamount to violence
then the opposite must be true a violent
act is really just another form of
speech
don't think of it as me cracking you in
the head with a bat think of it as a
disagreement
with you by reading you a strongly
worded letter with a nail at the end of
it
this is what happened at the washington
post a writer retweets a joke and a
co-worker calls him out on twitter as
opposed to doing the adult thing which
is ignore it or if you're pissed off you
walk over to his office and you tell
them why but you see doing it face to
face takes a little internal fortitude
something you couldn't find at the wapo
or any similar outlet because it's
mostly babies these days
so instead you know i'll just run to
twitter and have all my like-minded
thin-skinned unhappy friends gang up on
you because their safety in numbers even
if half those numbers are really bots
of course you could just not laugh at
the joke you don't find funny because
you know you aren't the center of the
universe
unless copernicus was wrong you know
scientists haven't had a great record
lately
what does he know
but adults do that and these people
aren't adults they're brats who see
cooperation as a weakness and tantrums
as heroism so they shut down discourse
they call you evil and that's the end of
it see we don't have a lot of adults in
media anymore they find mean tweets to
be hateful speech but endorse violence
or harassment in the name of justice
whether it's blm
antifa or joy behar when she runs out of
foundation and hosts his moon pies
that logic is as upside down as a joe
biden bike ride
chief that was cheap
cheap
very cheap
so the wapo staffer continued to crap on
her co-workers like she mistook ex-lax
for a brownie
until she got canned thankfully so you
don't settle stuff privately you don't
run to twitter to look for allies in
your personal crusade i bring this up as
a contrast to sotomayor she violated
this new golden rule in discourse she
treated an ideological adversary as a
human being which is now lacking these
days these days if you disagree with
someone well a wise man he said it
better than i ever could
and if you disagree with me that you sir
are worse than hitler and if you
disagree with me you are worse than
hitler and if you disagree with me you
sir are worse than hitler and if you
disagree with me you're worse than
hitler and if you disagree with me
you're a racist homophobe who is worse
than hitler and if you disagree with me
that you're probably a racist nazi who's
worse than hitler
wow that was a while ago
but i called it like a babe ruth home
run
and it's also hard to believe how much
better looking i got since then
sorry caitlyn you know you weren't the
only one who got hotter with age
[Applause]
welcome to the show by the way always a
pleasure
i know at least for me
but you could say i transitioned from
hunky to super hunky
and i want that to be my pronoun
but i am like a fine wine the older i
get the more i'm worth the better my
taste and i still enjoy a good quirking
still i won't hold my breath waiting for
the other networks to show people
getting along even if they disagree
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
david rooks for the chess news network
covering how political divisions are
tearing apart friendships marriages and
sewing circles here's a couple of things
they're in love right now sir sir
sir did you and your wife vote the same
in the last election uh no um she voted
republican i voted democrat it was okay
it's fine and miss did you know that
your husband still texts his
ex-girlfriend um i thought you'd leave a
reader from your phone he has two phones
okay well i have two phones for work you
lying son of a [ __ ] you work at burger
king well at least one of us knows how
to cook you work at the drive-through no
one of us knows how to drive okay proof
that different political views doom any
relationship back to you grimm
[Applause]
it would be nice if my counterparts
might show that clip of sotomayor
praising thomas like a school kid i want
less division
but they probably can't because if you
said nice things about clarence thomas
you might as well say nice things about
hitler
and if you disagree with me on that then
you certainly are worse than what's his
name
let's welcome
she's so athletic she can run laps
around democrats wearing stilettos fox
news contributor caitlyn jenner
his comedy's like his time as a cab
driver in both cases he drives people
away
host of fox across america jimmy failure
so patriotic betsy ross sent her a
friend request former deputy national
security adviser katie mccarlen
and she looks like a million bucks
thanks to inflation
fox's contributor cat tip
katelyn
we had a little exchanged words in the
green room and uh you seemed like you
were pretty perturbed with me about
something i said
um oh never gray no
uh there are a few things actually i
just want to say one thing about your
opening first which one
um honestly i am i am so impressed with
clarence thomas to be able to know all
the names of all the people yes uh at
the courthouse at the supreme court
right and their kids and when their
birthdays are and all that sort of stuff
at for me at this point in my life
i have a hard time remembering my own
name
see what i mean
yeah
try naming yourself think about that it
is the hardest thing in the world yes
yes but you did say you did say on
friday's show yes okay you said on
friday show one that you were very
excited for me to be here and i
appreciate that and i'm excited to be
with all of you hey girl um but
thank you
but
you also made a comment about me about
how you know i changed my life i went
from uh being a hurdler to a wearing a
girdle yeah yeah
it's a girdler or something like that
yes and a very funny at my expense yes
but it was it was honestly it was very
good i i enjoyed the show and i'm i'm
very excited to be here it's uh yeah
always a pleasure to have you on and we
continue to have as long as i get to
insult you because that's what i love
this is what friends do you're supposed
to insult each other
make fun of each other thank you even
people that i don't i can't stand him
that's true but um you know we we still
get along you know it could work right
right because i mean i'm like i'm very
tolerant you're a white supremacist
notice how i didn't laugh at that one
a little too close to home
i actually i am i'm actually thrilled
you're back i was here last week dana
was hosting yeah and uh normally you
know when you're guest hosting the
biggest late night show in the country
you have big shoes to fill but in this
case it was a size three
so she was
tough out here yeah i love you
i love you it's a tough crowd and by the
way
i do look like a figure skater who let
himself go during the lockdown
i've got to be the lyft guy now they
can't pick me up anymore
but
i was just going to ask you where your
lion was but i don't know anybody
remembers zigfried and roy
yeah
stab him
i always took this as more of a tiger
king crowd but all right
i still love you i still love all of you
um i actually did love your monologue
because it's so true they can't have us
get along and the joke of it is okay
they've always gotten along even at a
scotus level like no one likes to talk
about this but rbg and anton and scalia
were great friends and in that regard
politics is always like pro wrestling
you know at the end of the match the
fans of the macho man and jake the snake
beat the hell out of each other in the
parking lot well jake the snake and the
macho man go to hooters you know what
i'm saying and i only know that cause
i'm the guy at hooters you know what i
mean but that's our politics i don't
know if that's a good thing
i mean the idea of what you said it
makes total sense but it's like so you
rile up the audiences and then you go
off and you high-five it right well this
is what i want to say to her credit i
don't think she was trying to rile up
the audience that's the part that i
think is so ridiculous that she has to
justify being friends with a supreme
court justice like we're a bunch of fat
spoiled children at their birthday party
right like i'm sorry i'm friends with a
guy who doesn't want to play red rover
but he can still have cake and a toy
like how old are we i think it's stupid
so i was actually for this one i was i
was actually happy with her for at least
acknowledging that there is like some
cross-pollination between the two sides
but she did admit to being ideological
in a big way and if you remember obama
famously scolded the supreme court for
legislating from the bench but she was
basically apologizing for the fact that
they might not be able to this time
around which is sad yeah what do you
think kt see i think that it's
interesting that she did she never talks
publicly right and the fact that she
came out and talked about how great
clarence thomas was they've got about
six decisions that are going to come out
in the next couple of weeks um
everything from um you know from
immigration to abortion to gun rights to
elections integrity and i think that
they're very nervous in the supreme
court that they're going to start having
assassination attempts that that's going
to rile the country up and so i think
what she was doing was preempting that
and saying he's a really good guy he's
my friend and i bet you'll see more
justices come out in the next week to do
similar things oh that's like if we see
somebody else start talking about
kavanaugh
what's her name kagan
yeah yeah god i'm terrible another one
named kagan no everyone went with it
they thought you were saying oh like
yeah she's great we love her we love her
they're really gonna have other justices
going he's really not a bad guy don't
kill him
well we've gone really really really
down a bad bad ass cat you know you're a
lot like uh uh clarence thomas and what
way
well
i mean
i'm not on the supreme court yet no no
no no no
but
you know i never like we i i never air
your dirty laundry publicly we always
whenever we've got issues
fortunately you make up dirty laundry
yes
which is way worse than the actual dirty
laundry that you may have after knowing
me all these years and you air that
instead which is the best when i have
like random grandmothers messaging me on
facebook saying they hope i get help
with my heroine addiction
that i don't have
[Applause]
uh but yeah no i mean there's anything
else or you know just well i think
there's a my theory is that the reason
why okay it's an adult
non-adult divide like in the workplace
like you see these young people that
don't know how to act like adults right
they don't know how to like they they
believe that living that they're living
their personal life at work yeah and
that's and i wonder if it's because the
supreme court no they have a job for
life so you got to get along and number
two they're not online so they don't get
pulled into a lot of this stuff right i
also think that there's just a failure
to acknowledge intentions
i thought what she said was so great
just hey you know we have different
ideas about how to help people right
where now you assume the worst intention
so if i say that i don't want the
government to give something to people
because the government can't give
anything without taking from someone
else but anyway
people say okay that means that she's
saying that people shouldn't have that
which is really not the case i it's not
the same to say that the government's
not the best you know entity to handle
something
um it doesn't mean i don't care about
the issue but now it's a lot of assuming
the worst intentions of other people
demonizing them yeah you're not just
different you're not just wrong you're
evil but you're just saying once you're
evil people die yeah exactly right no i
prefer people to starve yeah
i want them to suffer before they die
yeah please take that out of context and
put that on a loop
all right up next hillary sounds the
alarm on wokeness that'll do more harm
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else